wow so this one is going to end  in a in a spectacular perpetual uh  peter do you think it's time to go to  the other game because there it looks  like  raja has messed up big time black spawn  on a2 knight a5  played uh knight d4 runs into rook d for  king d4 knight b3 picking up that rook  how is white fighting against knight b3  here yeah  for the moment i'm struggling to see why  white is not  supposed to design it looks like uh  night beast is coming or  can yeah no this is this is just lost i  mean we have  probably this game was yeah and and 10  more designs i mean just some  incredible performance by magnus okay  rajabov had to  blunder something i don't know what  happened let's just go back to moves  ah okay so it it at least got very very  tricky with all these pins  and with black spawn by the way we are  seeing this  perpetual check or